one of the things that I've realized is
that the same way you design games
designing a great game and designing a
great company are not all that different
in a great game you have clear goals you
know what you're trying to do it's very
clearly defined what you're trying to do
you're getting a lot of feedback and
rewards right either that be from points
or achievement search right you're
getting constant feedback loops
the challenge level is appropriate
you're focused on learning one thing at
a time the skill level is appropriate
where you want to be and probably the
most important thing about games when we
play games we take a certain kind of
mindset if I'm playing a game and I I
expect to lose I expect to have
challenges in fact that's the whole
point right if you play a game and
there's never a challenge
why are we even doing it right and so I
have tried to cultivate all four of
those things in my company right we set
clear goals where it's like okay we're
going to try to
have this metrics this specific metric
like our email subscriber list we're
going to try to increase it by this
amount and here's how we're going to do
it over this quarter or we're going to
try to get a new game in this category
that we're going to have a prototype
ready to go in two weeks right clear
goals we have something that allows us
to have daily focus and feedback what I
love is the rule of three I think I
first learned this from Chris Bailey
Facebook the productivity project but
I've applied it at every level of my
company so
what it is is you have everybody post
their three daily goals right what are
the top three things that I want to
focus on and three is really important
because we all have an infinite laundry
list of stuff to do right we're never
going to finish our to-do list but if
you can finish your most important three
things you can make an enormous amount
of progress and so and we scale that to
every level of the company so every team
we have we have three weekly goals we
have monthly goals we have quarterly
goals and so everything kind of scales
down and I even built this into my own
like personal life like I have a thing
the level up Journal which I've made
which I've got it just has a journal
that just it fits in your pocket and has
three goals three habits and then a
little gratitude practice and and so
every piece of it by focusing on very
few things and making those the priority
it makes a big difference and then
lastly with the mindset we set very
aggressive goals and it's okay not to
hit them right like a game when you want
to win you take winning seriously but
you don't cry when you lose a game right
you say okay what did we what can we
learn from this how do we get better and
starting to take that attitude and
approach it sometimes easier than others
for sure but like cultivating that
mindset and focusing on what's important
and making sure that the goals are clear
and everybody knows what they are and
you're moving day to day that's that's
how I structure the company and it's
again it came from just the principles
of design applying them to to what we do
and I found it to be really powerful
if people in the company are posting for
instance the the rule of three there's
three priorities for the day where are
they posting these so we have a company
Discord so we'll have a we have a
channel and our company Discord that
everybody posts their three goals for
the day this is a separate one for
weekly goals separate one for monthly
goals and a separate one for quarter
legals and so you could always look back
and see what everybody is doing at any
given point if you care to at the main
focus it helps also helps us stay
connected right because we're 100 remote
team now so even though I may not talk
to a given person or see a given person
I can quickly glance and see what's most
important to them right now right and
then so it keeps us all connected and
accountable
two questions the first is is there any
follow-up on those three or is it just
the act of someone publicly stating
their priorities that makes everyone
feel connected and hopefully gives them
some felt sense of accountability that
you think leads to sort of better
output let's start there so the daily
there's not much follow-up on The Daily
it's about staying connected and I think
it just forces you to plan right it
forces you to assess for yourself okay
what actually is important to me a lot
of people will just start checking
emails and going down rabbit holes and
they're working they are working but
they're not doing what's important right
they're just doing whatever's in front
of them and so this forces just as a
habit it forces you to think things
through great point then for the
weeklies we do have that so we have our
weekly goals we have a check-in at the
end of the week where people will post
hey here were my goals for last week
here's how they went here are now my
goals for the next week or well you know
what can I do if I didn't meet a goal
what am I doing to fix it so there is
some accountability and I read through
those every week for the team and we
discuss and that's on Friday so people
are setting their priorities for the
following week on Friday correct